Speaker 1: All right, I want to follow up
this Neil Cavuto thing has gotten really,
really interesting. Yesterday, we
talked about Fox News host Neil Cavuto
literally begging his audience supplicating,
saying Get vaccinated, stop the politicization
of vaccines, and he has been essentially
ignored by his entire network. Now Neil
Cavuto is in a particular health situation.
Neil Cavuto has had multiple sclerosis for
quite some time. He had heart surgery. He
was vaccinated when he recently got COVID,
and he attributes having as mild the case as he
did. Statistically, he attributes that, of course,
it's all anecdotal individually, but statistically
he attributed to being vaccinated. So we looked
yesterday at multiple clips of him pleading
with his audience. Here is one such example
as a reminder to get us all on the same page.
Speaker 2: We lost five million globally to
this. We've lost nearly 800000 in the US. Take
the political speaking points and toss them.
For now, I'm begging you, toss them and think
of what's good not only for yourself, but for
those around you if you don't want to do it for
yourself. If you think it's a pain in the ass,
I get that right. But think of others around you.
I daresay people who experience this sort seen
loved ones who've been affected by this or have
ever died from this are not judging the wisdom of
mandates. They're wishing they got vaccinated
and they didn't. I don't let that happen.
Speaker 1: I'm so we suspected that based on
the reaction from other shows, which was to
say nothing about this shows on Fox to say nothing
about this and just keep hammering about vaccine
mandates and protests and all of this different
stuff. We suspected it that his audience might
not like this, and in fact, that's the case. So
yesterday there were some responses to Neil Cavuto
begging his audience about the vaccine shared, and
some people in his audience want him dead now. I
received death threats all the time
on this show and and many people in
media do. But it's interesting that his own
right wing audience, which he has fed, he's
built this monster over the last, however many
plus years that he's been on Fox News. I think
they very quickly the people that want me
dead are never people that were on my side.
The people that seem to want Neil Cavuto
dead are people that were fine with him,
they were viewers of his show, so let's take a
look at it. He shared some of these yesterday.
Speaker 2: We got T.J TJ, who also emails. It's
clear you've lost some weight with all this stuff.
Good for you, but I'm not happy with less of you.
I want none of you. I want you gone dead. Kaput,
finished. Get it now. Take your tube device deep.
Six It and you. Wow, that's a rather harsh Neil.
So but I figured I'd you down for The Sopranos
prequel. Yes, it does sound kind of like that. OK,
now we got Vince. Vince tweets, Hey guys, I bought
a new car after being told it was the best bet,
I blew up after I left the car lot. So now I'm
begging everyone to please buy the same car.
Sorry, I was just pretending to be Neil Cavuto,
Speaker 1: so I guess that the implication is
Cavuto only wants other people to get the vaccine
because he got it and the vaccine is terrible,
so he wants other people to experience the same
bad. I mean, it's crazy. It's bizarre, which
Speaker 2: I think is being a little
sarcastic there in that last tweet,
getting a little bit a little bit
better. So, OK, but I know you love that.
Speaker 1: The cringy nature of the
segment is not lost on me, by the way.
Speaker 2: Another tweet PolitiFact PolitiFact
biased Neil Cavuto has been fully vaccinated for
months and has been a vocal advocate about the
safety and efficacy of COVID vaccines publicly
and repeated repeatedly on air. This is not
a new position for him, which is true. Neal
is not a new position and that's kind of what
we were stressing. In all seriousness is, look,
this is something for the very beginning. I've
been saying that I think the better part of Valor
is if you haven't been vaccinated, it might
be a good idea for you to get vaccinated. I
understand those for religious personal reasons
don't want it, but I understand also the numbers.
Speaker 1: Now remember, we dealt earlier
with the religious thing. There's almost no
religions that actually ban vaccination, and
the ones that do are not prominent religions
for the most part in the United States or who
Speaker 2: do get vaccinated, the the bigger
the drop in cases. Absolutely. Yeah. Didn't
call on all receptive, you know, suddenly
that I got another one for you. From vagueness
aspiring to aspire tweets, Cavuto is the tigger
of talking heads. Say Head full of fluff, just
not the not cool like Tigger. And I think for
the record, we had our fact checkers look
at this. I think she is actually referring
making the correlation that you were like to bear
because he was the one that was full of fluff.
Speaker 1: OK, so now they're getting off into
into very strange stuff. So what's funny is maybe
this is new for Neil, but this is my inbox
every day. OK, let's put that aside. What's
not funny is that part of this reaction to Neil
Cavuto saying, Get vaccinated, we don't take the
politics out. Whatever part of it is a result of
coverage that Neil Cavuto has done. And in fact,
yesterday he did a story about vaccine mandates
triggering protests. He did. He put his signal
boosted again, that there are these wacky people
going to rallies merely to advocate against
vaccination and the fact that that's gotten
nonstop coverage on Fox News. It's part of
what has built this monster. So maybe don't cover
that, Neal, particularly since he supposedly does
sort of more of like a finance based show. I mean.
So I think it's a great thing that Neil Cavuto is
saying this on Fox is an audience that desperately
needs to hear it. I'm not surprised that his
audience turned on him. Listen, Trumpists. What
was the thing that got Trump is to turn on Trump
at that rally, and I don't even remember was it
Georgia was? It was a couple of months ago when
Trump said, I recommend the vaccine and freedom
too, but I recommend it that that completely vile,
committed Trump based audience booed Trump. So
we know that this is something that will get
the crowd to turn on you. But you can't ignore
the fact that Neil Cavuto has also participated
in some of this very same stuff through the
story choice that he's done on his program.
So that's what's going on. Not a big shock that
this is the way that his audience is reacting.